well
how are you greetings cristian casares the
las vegas metropolitan police
say governor steve slack was
responsible for causing their
car accident last sunday at
rainbow and basso streets according to the
incident report the governor was about
to turn during a light in  yellow
when the other car hit him officials
say that es life failed to
give way to the other driver and this caused
the accident so it is like he
received a ticket the driver
was also fined for driving at a
high speed
I tell you that a
County commissioners gave the green light Wednesday
for an underground transportation system
along the hotel zone Buen Company's proposed project
includes extending the Vigués Club through the
tourist stretch of Las Vegas,
allowing tourists to navigate through
tunnels  below the busy and the
script the deal is over 17
million dollars and will grow the current
t  circular branch at 29 miles will offer 51
stops to the airport the university the
south and the center of las vegas to obtain
the permits construction will begin in
the next 6 to 12 months
if you have seen an increase when going to the
supermarket it is not only the
prices of  food continues to rise and
this is due to a variety of factors
including a lack of workforce
closures due to the pandemic and even
weather issues as reported by
the nevada merchant associations are
also still seeing
pandemic related effects as
well as delays  in the piers
after a rise in cost to transport
goods from the Far East to Los
Angeles in the state of Nevada, it is one of
the most registered seismic activity,
so today
residents of the state are asked to participate in the
annual drill  known as del rey
nevadas shake up all this happening
at 10 21 in the morning businesses
government offices and schools is  Colares came
together to carry out safety measures
to protect themselves in the event of an
earthquake, including seeking refuge
under desks and door frames
as well as avoiding being near
windows or glass,
and there is a new effort to help
low-income families be able to  buy
your own homes
county commissioners approved a project of more than
100 homes that will be designed and
built near
character and buffalo streets to allow
people to achieve home
ownership the project is being
funded with the help of the office of
land administration and continue
pleasant temperatures today we will have a
semi-cloudy day with temperatures in
the mid-seventies we will have an increase
in temperatures for Friday when they
rise to the 80s I am Cristian Cáceres with
his brief news now in
Spanish good day
[Music]